hey Luke here at the outdoor boys
YouTube channel and this is my niece
Lucy and together we're going to forge a
fork you excited Lucy
[Music]
so my niece Lucy here is visiting from
Maine and she would like to do some
foraging so we need to come up with a
fun foraging project that her mother is
okay with would you like to do maybe
like a fork and a knife set like for her
like the kitchen and knife set
would you like is we're gonna make the
handle like this well that looks pretty
good
good plan all right we're gonna do this
we gotta get the snow off the forge
we've got to get a fire started and then
we've got to get all of our stuff out
here and all set up okay you ready let's
do it
all right clean off the anvil get off
knock off all that snow scrub that tread
and scrub all the rest off
all right let's see we can find steel to
my steel pile
[Applause]
oh here we go there we go yeah yeah
that's gonna be your fork you know what
this is
it's called what does it feel like
[Music]
what you do to shove it right there in
the orange part
okay smack that thing alright hit his
hard yeah right there right on the tip
I'm gonna get it and then you're gonna
hit it then I'm gonna hit it and you're
gonna hit it and you're gonna hit it
everywhere I hit okay
they're right along there so I feel like
this how you get all that scale off
let's go that great tip comes off okay
I'm gonna put it in the fire and when I
tell you to scrub it you scrub it okay
let's scrub it
okay screw it down
they scrub it
[Music]
that look about right maybe they'll pick
it up and put the pork right there okay
hold it steady yeah yeah hold it steady
as you can
okay so stick it in the snow what do you
think I think it's gonna turn out really
cool is that fun all right well let's
say I go grab some dinner and show your
mom and dad what you got so far then
here in a couple days I'll show you how
to do the handle okay okay hey why don't
you grab some snow balls and put them on
the fire we got to put the fire out just
keep your face away with there we go
all right so we got Lucy here in the
workshop and we're going to grind up the
fork to make it all nice and pretty to
get the shape we want put the tines in
and then polish it up good
all right let's do it and Nathan's in
here with winter gloves and no pants and
he's gonna help us out isn't that right
Nathan now what we do is gonna grind
this round make this whole part nice and
round and smooth before I cut it off
okay
all right Lucy now the hard part we've
got to polish this up the 120 grit has
all these little marks in it so we're
gonna take this 240 grit sandpaper and
sand it to all the marks are gone then
you're gonna sand it with the 600 until
all the 240 marks are gone then you're
gonna sand it with the 800 - all the 600
marks are gone you're gonna sand it with
the 1500 so Lucy is that taking a lot of
time to do that by hand well try this
out here grab before these power tools
shall we
that looks so far great we're gonna have
to cut the tines in and if we missed you
know it'll happen to your fork
absolutely ruined that's right let's say
we draw it on with a sharpie first how
do you think that looks do you like it
or does it you want it deeper think
that's good right there
hey Lucy see that blue part right there
huh how would you like to have the whole
fork look like that
look at the middle tongs
[Applause]
[Applause]
well guys it's another day and I need to
head to work and while I'm at work
Lucy's gonna work on the leather handle
for the floor what we're gonna be doing
is cutting the leather into strips and
cutting the strip's into perfect squares
and we need to make enough squares to
stack up four inches a leather handle
okay just put the leather in the slot
right there and then you just pull it
down see that makes a perfect strip of
leather all right do you think you can
make it strip go for it and you want to
make these 3/4 by 3/4 inch squares hey
can you do it okay Lucy for the next
step we got to drill some holes in the
leather so what you're gonna do is gonna
take a couple of these okay they're
about the same size hold them and then
you've got to get it in the dead center
you got to really take your time and put
it in the center then kind of inspect
them see how I do all right Lucy miss me
wall is gone okay well let's look at
this I've got some concerns all right
you can see here these strips of leather
are really thin and they're not
compacting very tight I think they're
too thin and too soft it might work but
Lucy's leaving in a couple days so if it
doesn't we don't have time to fix it so
we're gonna go to a plan B and try some
harness leather and that should make
this more durable as well so we'll see
how that works all right Lucy want some
harness leather that should do it
yeah no harness leathers wax - see see
how it's whack see it's designed to
protect against rain it's what they make
saddles and stuff out of so I think this
has a better chance of surviving I'm
gonna make these 1-inch squares like
that
[Music]
okay one all right there we go that's
four inches of leather right there all
right Lucy dump it in all right let
those soak for a few minutes
slip it on like silk wipe off this
excess glue here there we go we got the
leather all glued and stacked up now all
we need to do is put it in the oven and
dry it at about 175 degrees Fahrenheit
that'll take a couple hours maybe then
we'll shape it and we'll be really close
to done so that looking pretty cool are
you excited yeah all right let's put in
the other okay and lay it on that cookie
sheet all right it's looking pretty good
there's a few gaps here and there but
hopefully that won't be a big deal but
we're gonna go and try to grind the
edges off and make this a nice round
handle
I kept hitting the metal on the belt and
it scuffs up that blue finish so just
covered it in some painters tape to
protect it a little bit while we do this
all right now got some 800 grit on the
belt sander here and we're gonna go and
try to polish up this handle what do you
think of that I like it does it feel
good in the hand well there we go guys
that's the finished product and it looks
pretty darn cool handle feels great the
blued steel looks pretty awesome
a little piggy tail on the back looks
cool you happy with the finished product
you excited to go use it well let's go
take a day hop okay let's go let's go
use this thing we're gonna test it out
how's it working is it nice and stabby
good well guys we hope you enjoyed this
video if you'd like to see more great
videos from the outdoor boy YouTube
channel don't forget to
[Music]
[Laughter]
thanks for watching we hope you guys
enjoyed this video if you'd like to see
more great videos from the outdoor voice
youtube channel don't forget to click
subscribe we put out new videos every
week and don't forget to hit that Bell
button so you'll get notified when we
put out another great video